mientras Putin celebra la llamada
anexión de cuatro regiones de Ucrania
para Rusia la realidad sobre el terreno
es una historia muy diferente los
reveses en el campo de batalla están
provocando duras críticas de algunos de
los aliados más cercanos del kremlin
durante el fin de semana el líder de
chechenia que ha reclutado a sus propios
hijos para luchar en la guerra criticó
la acción militar de Rusia pidiendo el
uso de armas nucleares de bajo
rendimiento en Ucrania comentarios que
provocaron una respuesta inmediata del
ex jefe de la Cia y del General de
cuatro estrellas estadounidense David
petros
solo para dar una hipótesis
responderíamos liderando un esfuerzo de
la otan colectivo que eliminaría cada
fuerza convencional rusa que podamos ver
e identificar en el campo de batalla en
Ucrania y también en crimea y cada barco
en el mar Negro
el lunes el portavoz del kremlin
dimitrip Scott intentó rebajar la
atención diciendo que el enfoque militar
de Rusia no debe regirse por las
emociones diciendo a los periodistas
en nuestro país el uso de las armas
nucleares se produce solo sobre la base
de lo que se establece en la doctrina
pertinente
pero el comentario no ha calmado los
temores en occidente putina amenazado
repetidamente con recurrir a las armas
nucleares en Ucrania recientemente dijo
que el bombardeo atómico estadounidense
de Hiroshima y nagasaki sentó un
precedente para el uso de armas
nucleares